[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est parti au mercy de jarret carte là
encore un moment
des minutes et bien voilà mentir tu as
vu le phénomène
je ne t'ai pas les lauriers avant le
déjeuner et à table je me suis retenu de
temps que j'ai pu pour que tu es une
idée mecque du personnage que l'on ne
vienne pas encore me reprocher d'être le
fautif et d'exaspérer monsieur ya
longtemps que tu l'avais pas eu sous les
jeux tu gardes est sans doute le
souvenir d'un enfant maintenant tu as vu
le jeune homme si j'ose dire
un page de raphaël des cheveux en vrai
jusqu'au milieu du dos ou une bague
grosse comme ça une chaîne de poules de
luxe au poignet un mouchoir jaune à
faire trier un cacatoès et avaient tous
un mépris au coin des lèvres un air de
pape en france et dès qu'on se permet de
devancer la parole tu as vu ça s'il a vu
mon fils mon nuit ça me ressemble à ce
taux reste bas
voilà voilà la nouvelle génération voilà
comment ils sont traités fait cela moi
je porte un costume tout simple tu vois
jean ferrat tous les trois ans mais tu
as pu remarquer la chemise à jabot de
monsieur et a vu les carreaux de ses
chaussettes et l'ineffable couleur de sa
cravate
on se lève la peau 20 ans de sa vie à
vendre des appareils de chauffage pour
arriver tant bien que mal à élever ses
enfants
et brusquement pas ce qui l'a poussé à
celui à trois poils en dessous du nez tu
vois à tata chez toi
l'espèce de prince oriental couvert de
soirée
bon alors lequel dell de temps en temps
relevé la paupière ou laisser tomber
amoureux
voilà ma vie mon vieux tu as foutrement
bien fait resté garé son vrai nom mais
non tu n'es pas mon avis je trouve que
tu exagères de vos cours à ce qui
concerne charles et son frère et paraît
enfin pareil tout en apportant un type
exactement opposées aiguille c'est autre
chose il tient milieu entre le mécano
les quat'z'arts est toujours salle comme
un cochon diffusé à des couleurs sous
tous les joies immenses autres poèmes tu
sors d'une poche pile électrique dans
une autre sans parler des bobines de fil
d'affaires roues dentées tubes en
caoutchouc et autres saloperies celui là
c'est le peintre poète inventeur je ne
sais pas laquelle ces trois spécialités
n'attendra la gloire pour le moment elle
se donne au droit tu la preuve
aujourd'hui mais je te dis c'est kif kif
personne n'existe pour lui sur la terre
si tu n'as pas le bonheur
être un beau edison ou puis sacko
picasso du peuple ont crevé jeunes à
crottes de chien unique au sinistre
imbécile picasso voilà le grand homme
j'ai vu l'autre jour un tableau de cet
oiseau là à la demande des deux galeries
c'est bien simple j'ai failli tomber à
la renverse complètement savez je me
charge d'en faire autant tu peux appeler
leurs places d'honneur le père de fait
119 pts le tour et voilà c'est lui le
génie est rangé le type qui te dit
froidement si on n'a pas de jennir n'a
rien à [ __ ] sur la tête il vaut mieux
faire place nette
place nette mon vieux tu entends ça à 17
ans il tabasse à s'en soucier dans le
blanc de mails place nette à lyon à la
balançoire s'est exécuté par ailleurs
maintenant il faut t'y fais ma joie ça
te fait rire
ben pas moi enfin ne parlons pas de
ranger il m'inquiète pas il me prend
pour un couillon le blâme est que cette
son âge mais c'est mon friz et oxygénées
qui commence à me courir m'a franchement
moi je les trouvais très gentilles à une
bonne figure il devient rouge comme un
enfant des piles oui il ya un monde je
pense que tu as tort de prendre sa
réserve pour la manque
si tu veux mon avis je ne crois du d'une
grande timidité et est très sensible
aussi évidemment tv timide oui hélas
clos le tonnerre snr par dessus le
marché monsieur praver crise
tu vois ce bronze joufflu devenir blanc
cammas est à ce prix écarlate et quitter
la table en gloussant comme une femme
avec une voix le chat très bons
aujourd'hui s'est tenu à carreau
d'accord mais au moins je connais mon
lapin je tiens bon logerait sur bon nez
bien qu'est ce que je vais faire pour
toi
la voici avant-hier quand je t'ai
téléphoné pour te demander si tu voulais
bien déjeuné avec nous je venais de
passer un quart d'heure désagréable
il ya deux mois voyant qu'il n'y aurait
rien à tirer de ce zèbre là pour ses
études
j'avais un peu du de chasselas qu'il le
prenne dans sa boîte d'assurance c'était
bien
j'ai dit à charles je me refuse à lui
donné ce surnom protestent de lolo dont
l'affublent depuis quinze ans sa mère et
sa grand mère je dis mon petit je te met
le pied à l'étrier qui n'a plus qu'à
être un peu sérieux et à apprendre un
métier matière fusent c'est indigne de
lui tu penses lui il veut s'occuper le
chiffon faire faire des robes mais des
robes pour sedat fou quoi complètement
cinglé résultat il a passé quinze jours
dans ce bureau l'a foutu
ni plus ni moins sans explication on
était dans une lettre de remerciements h
à cela c'est par lui que j'ai été averti
avanthier et il m'a gentiment fait
comprendre d'ailleurs que les assurances
n'avait pas besoin de ce genre d'artiste
sur quoi il a parfaitement raison mais
également fait comprendre avec beaucoup
de discrétion que vis-à-vis des autres
employés le genre que tu as pu remarquer
chez mon acrobates n'était pas non plus
d'un effet souhaitable tout s'est
vraiment délicieux entendre te vois
ouais depuis 48 heures le nommer charles
dit lolo ne prend même plus ses
ondulations oxygénée dans les bureaux
d'assurance
alors j'ai pensé henry mon cousin c'est
le seul de mes parents ou amis qu'ils
soient dans une branche artistique je
lui demander un conseil depuis deux
jours je me tiens à 4 pour ne pas
traiter charles communaux mairie
julien dira pas un mot parce que je
voulais auparavant que tu vois le
phénomène il a pu se douter mais
attention à table nous avons parlé de
choses et d'autres et il a filé rebouché
alors jeté ce que tu penses c'est plus
que fier de lui je sais plus je dois
dire que tu m'embrasses un peu je suis
éditeur je ne vois pas trop le rapport
qu'il peut dire vrai j'avais pensé qu'on
produit s'il était dessinateur je ne dis
pas je pourrais me présenter un confrère
spécialisé où elle n'aura vu de mode
mais en face ce n'est pas son cas ah non
c'est l'autre qui décide lui très potes
et chiffons travail dans le génie
d'aspiration desilets tu portes
alors je te répète je ne vois vraiment
pas en quoi la jambe et eddy l'édition
se sont tout de même des artistes qui
s'occupe de ça peut-être que dans ce
milieu là il s'intéresserait à quelque
chose mais tu me dis qu'il a la passion
de la couture ah ça c'est bien ça s'est
avéré une femme avec une feuille de
papier à cigarette
il a droit à un massage en deux temps
prouve m'en étais confectionne une robe
sa chambre en déplaise c'est pas une
chambre c'est un atelier couture avec
des fanfreluches dans tous les coins et
avec un bout que thérèse 10 est
extraordinaire moi je connais rien et
bien là alors quoi pourquoi es tu as des
l'enfermer dans une compagnie
d'assurances que veux tu qu'il y fasse
et pour quoi parles-tu d'édition alors
qu'il a un métier tout trouvé qu'ils ne
s'intéressent qu'à lui tu vois tout même
page de près de cfoot et cela au sérieux
mais la côte est alors que sur la
couture doit pas trouver normal que j'ai
un fils de 18 ans couturier
métier enfin le métier comme je le
comprends que tu trouves un milieu très
spécial la demande
dessinateur dépendantes est ce que tu
crois sont neuf fois sur dix les
personnages
un peu particulier pour prier la vierge
pourrait pas envie que mon fils de ganac
ses personnages
tu sais j'en connais aussi plusieurs qui
ne sent pas de ces personnages dont tu
parlais surpoids sûr et puis la question
n'est pas là tu me dis je ne veux pas
que mon fils devienne un de ces
personnages là il en est lui même autant
qu'on peut tant m comment il en est tu
dis toi même à chaque mois mais si je le
savais les canadairs et non mais c'est
pas mon métier depuis un quart d'heure
qui me parle de ses bagues de ses
principes et de ses cheveux oxygénés tu
me parles de ses crises de nerfs de sa
voix de femmes tu sais je le connais
bien
rien du tout hop pardon et puisque tu me
demandes un cancer je te dirai regarde
les choses comme elles sont charles est
né comme ça il n'y peut rien et toi non
plus charles est une femme c'est évident
c'était évident quand il avait 5 ans je
m'en souviens très bien et tu va le
mettre dans une compagnie d'assurances
auprès des femmes qui travaillent dans
les compagnies d'assurance
oui mais lui il a le vrai goût des
femmes il aime les planètes du bijou les
des robes on peut aimer l'erreur d'être
dans ce projet mais robin non oui toi tu
aimes les jupons ça n'a aucun rapport
oui enfin quoi bon alors ça ça c'est du
nouveau gm fisc est une chose je t'en
prie ne me répète mais quand je te
l'apprendre parfaitement où tu refusais
le te l'avouer je refusais parfaitement
parce que jusqu'ici j'ai partagé l
famille gens normaux parce que si notre
grand-père était magistrat rive est en
tort et quand l'état lancé les choses
pareilles
et il établit que son arrière-petit-fils
était foutue au lit mais qu'est ce
qu'ils devraient faire et là c'est ton
père est sur le coup ça j'en suis sûr eh
ben ça arrange est tous avec toi aussi
ça s'arrangera et qui ne sera pas obligé
d'en mourir tous mettaient les semences
trouve rien de serveurs ont compris en
apporter un petit mais toujours en
colère mon calme toi ne prend aucune
décision est réfléchie en regardant bien
les choses
onfray c'est le tour des boutons si tu
veux le savoir les choses il n'ya
révoltante la foulée on se sauve elle ce
petit [ __ ]
avec ses grosses fesses et ça colle des
gens vous mangerez la plume acrobat x se
brûler est solide avance douter quelque
part le bret a plus le membre je suis
désolé mais je dois absolument partir si
je veux être à mon rendez vous de toi
j'ai entendu quelques clics
[Musique]
encore une petite seringue si je
comprends bien le moins qu'on puisse
dire est qu'il a un caractère violent et
un vocabulaire toujours choisi j'emmerde
avec lui c'est du pin pon que vous voyez
la balle revient toujours
moi quand j'ai pas entendu crier nom de
dieu et le mot de cambronne val fois
dans la journée
je sais que quelque chose ne va pas oui
une petite grippe et il a un peu de
fièvre
aujourd'hui c'est semaine anglaise étant
donné la température à 12h30 nous en
compterons bien ta de plus d'ici ce soir
sa chérie pouilles ne change pas il est
toujours plein de fournir à tout ça pour
la fougue les séries mais c'est le
secret de sa jeunesse on regarde et lui
l'échec
il n'a pas le ventre qu'elle du matin au
soir il est parfait je suis sensible à
cette revue de détail l'étude permettra
de répondre qu en général si je perds tu
dis c'est que j'ai des raisons de fond
qui donc j'espère bien le comble serait
d'entendre crier pour rien au revoir -
viesly peau je suis désolé partir si
vite maintenant il est déjà trois jours
- ne vous mettez pas et même si on l'a
de nouveau
il aime s'en aller maman tu as droit à
ces hommages je le trouve tout à fait
charmant je n'avais plus vu depuis
longtemps un garçon si disque live c'est
bien aimé mais c'est dommage qu'il ne
soit pas mariés il refait un mari
adorable oui nous avons dû nouveau le
café froid maman je vais dire à léonie
de terre et chaud bien mon nom sans
trait je laime que froid attention quoi
sert elle je remets quand il saura plus
tard ce fait vous savez que personne ne
peut plus rire que montre quand vous
racontez une histoire bon serveur je ne
sais pas dans quelle mesure vous allez
trouver celle là est résistif et bien
des enfants je vous annonce que nous
comptons dans la famille spécimens
d'individus que l'on n'avait jamais
rencontré jusqu'ici
lolo puisque c'est le surnom grotesque
dont vous l'affublé lolo autrement dit
charles bien peu à peine le réseau doit
prononcer ce mot alors là tu m'étonnes
mais c'est pas le mot qui me gêne c'est
sa signification
de quoi faire charles
autrement dit lolo est averti voilà j'ai
pu plus redoutée depuis 10 minutes et
vous étiez aussi bien que moi converti
converti à quoi pense au communisme
j'espère je ne pense pas que ce serait
son genre 1 1
quoi
[Musique]
vous dit rien c'est ennuyeux il a besoin
d'une opération
là ma mère à mon innocence et délicieux
ça ne veut pas dire que j'en ai attrapé
le mal a dit ça veut dire qu'il n'est
pas un homme
si vous mettez points sur les i qu'est
ce que vous nous racontez la hypo
j'étais là quand il est né
mettons solutionne pas grand chose
d'être normalement constitué décidé moi
je n'étais pas du tout moi je nageais
complètement ça évidemment voir
évidemment et bien évidemment notre
pauvre loulou est plutôt efféminé il est
bien évident qu'on ne peut pas
sérieusement le prendre pour un champion
de boxe non bah vous n'avez pas l'air
d'être enchanté plus que sa mission oui
c'est aux prises pour écouter pour dès
qu'il a eu cinq ou six ans nous avons vu
cet enfant faire des robes ravissante à
ses poupées avec des morceaux des tofs
qu'il ramassait à droite et à gauche
nous l'avons vu grandir et nous étonner
par sa mémoire extraordinaire et ton van
lierop césaire de danseuses ses ongles
vernis et ses bacs de sibérie qui trouve
parfaitement raciste qui parlent trop
noblement auprès d'albert les gens vont
la reine des folles 20 janvier moi je
suis pas d'accord je peux arrêter
c'est peut-être aussi pour moi d'y
rentrer ben moi j'ai laissé mes roues
non vous le dirais c'est un peu tard au
jeudi c'est un peu tard tu aurais pu s'y
prendre plus tôt
ça se passera pas comme ça je m'en fiche
publiée avant de tenir debout il y avait
l'autre comme vous par les grands pays
depuis bientôt 20 ans que nous vivons
ensemble
j'avoue je m'y habitue pas je ne prends
pas ça change je vous aime savoir
jean-paul eymond exprime ma pensée s'ils
sont grotte au public
ça prouve au moins que je ne suis pas
d'effets lumineux au langage est un
langage des régimes qui dit ce qu'il
veut dire pour un étranger ça pourrait
prouver aussi tu as passé ta vie dans un
corps de garde mon avis tu ne parlais
pas autrement au tailleur à boules à
part maman ne tue vos tout sur ce
chapitre
moi aussi je parle comme une lavandière
et les enfants à son langage viril nous
a marqué le parc b me plaisent leçon à
recevoir de personne
je peux passer la tête le groupe ne vend
bien des gens quand un langage des
marquises qui n'ont pas la conscience
aussi bête que l'année et que tu en mer
et que j'emmerde
à pied arsenal dans cette tâche connaît
le couplet je te dis nous sommes dans un
corps de garde est le langage brute des
images et des gens qui n'ont pas passé
leur vie à apprendre le pays
tu n'aimes pas tu es tu ne connais pas
le bridge le sénateur est pas comme
certains officiers qui se la couler
douce à nice ou à montpellier à
dunkerque
mesdames si vous voulez bien avec les
stukas on enfile alors énergique et de
noisettes sur la cafetière
merci pour le shampoing tu n'avais guère
être officiel si cela cela coulait 6,12
on ne va pas viser pas envie c'est du
tout je me cherche un prendre du galon
tu l'as cherché puisque tu étais sept
français ne peut pas prendre de la
lavande et sordide de souza fait et dans
la réserve en cours alors encore une
fois tu vois pas pourquoi qui a tenu
absolument rester là parce que par celle
que parce que tu pouvais pas faire
autrement au dos pas du tout point du
tout parce que je pourrais pas faire
autrement parce que pour tout te dire
j'ai toujours eu horreur le ces gens-là
braqué deux banques
des affiches siège officiel en fête et
de l'armure général et spécialement les
officiers anglais avec leur taylor leur
ba dinh nam étudiants qu'à dunkerque ils
ont beaucoup pris le thé moi je t'ai le
pauvre couillon le prof français qui
s'est cassé la gueule voilà ce que le
fait exprès et ben moi je te dis à ta
place je l'aurais fait exprès d'être
lieutenant mais sans preuve mon repas
chaud mais sa percée la date c'est bien
lu quelques-uns aussi le heureusement et
surtout hauteur alors tu vois tu vois de
quoi te plains tu j'ai de toute façon tu
n'as rien lui casser oui au fait c'est
vrai patron hippolyte
comment pouvez vous dire une chose
pareille d'abord je vous ferai remarquer
que vous vous êtes connus et marie après
l'année eh bien il est possible à ma
femme de regret tête avec tan au but
mais pas eu le bon esprit de supprimer
celui qui se trouve aujourd'hui son mari
elle n'aurait jamais eu ainsi l'occasion
de faire un jour sa connaissance sur une
plage du midi un set et elle a été
charmant il vous fiançailles le soir du
bal des cocotiers et et reggae quand on
vient d'un rattachement de ne pas avoir
une jambe cassée s'arrêter là
le jour tu cesseras de nous dire des
âneries de ce goût là tu nous feras plus
que je pense est probablement ce que tu
peux aussi vous des fois vous disputez
ainsi avec terrain c'est elle qui répond
tout le temps autrement je te réponds
pour qu'ils ne fassent pas un monologue
sous prétexte que tu es en colère tu
tournes comme un ours entre les poteaux
et tu parles scène et il arrive que ça
dure une heure quand ça n'est pas une
demi journée
il n'y a pas dix salons dans la maison
et nous sommes là je préfère prendre
part à la conversation et dire mon mot
maman 10e temps en temps ça nous fait ce
qu'on appelle une conversation et
d'ailleurs je ne veux pas pourquoi cette
histoire d'officiers de sergent major
est venu se mettre au milieu
de quoi est-il question de quitter son
boulot nous le rappeler je disais des
choses n'allaient pas se passer comme ça
mais alors là tu aurais bien fait de
garder sa langue dans sa poche nous
voilà partis au mais je crée je ne
créerait pas du tout je dirai seulement
que je veux lui apprendre à vis oh moi
mademoiselle je vais rigoler les bagues
des bracelets je veux lui cherche une
permanence il va voir ça et pas plus
tard que ce soir
qu'est ce que tu vas finir et le [ __ ]
à la porte il sera géré à danser la
danse du ventre et jouer des cas sa
dette avec ses breloques bruce boudreau
me concerne simplement le [ __ ] à
l'appartement tuerait pas par quatre
chemins
monsieur ne veut pas travailler comme
tout le monde je veux mener la grande
vie et s'imaginent qu'en tortillon à sa
façon les morceaux que tu suis dans le
coup de pouce du génie des cas et vont
lui tomber tout rôti dans la boue et
alors qu'ils essaient et la preuve à ce
que c'est que la vie et qu'il est déjà
pas si facile de la gagner sa vie ce que
ces petits messieurs n'ont pas l'air de
savoir du tout
et quand ils auront ensuite deux ou
trois coups durs dans les gencives
commencera à comprendre que la maison
avait du bon et que son imbécile de pain
n'avait peut-être pas tout à fait tort
quand il essayait de nous inculquer
quelques principes et qui s'inquiétait
de son éducation
il comprendra qu'un homme doit être un
homme n a pas une espèce de sujet n'est
toujours occuper le front phromphan
francs luce et autres âneries de cette
espèce
bon alors si le comprends pas europe le
capturer le chef sait qu'il peut dire si
tu veux dire tout et tout ça si moi je
comprends bien toute cette scène depuis
un quart d'heure lorsqu'au cours de la
conversation que tu as eue avec ory tu
as découvert
enfin tu as accepté
ou tu as été forcé de reconnaître parce
qu'ils te lundi sans doute ce que tu
sais parfaitement comme moi depuis des
années que le loup est un garçon comme
les eaux n'est pas un garçon comme les
autres et c'est qu'on statue veulent
[ __ ] à la porte c'est parce que je ne
ferais pas d'un fils qui soit tu à l'eau
oui vraiment motivés ils excluent sur
madame je me mets à vos pieds vous
présente mais pas du tout j'ai lapin est
détestable qui déforme les voies d'une
phase que vous en découdre dimanche
prochain bon dieu sherman c'est une
responsabilité bien grande que vous me
confiez l'an dernier j'ai bénéficié de
la valeur symbolique de l'objet que
jamais à voir mais on ne vend pas tous
les ans la photo dédicacée du président
de me rappeler cette confusion où au
talent talent tu as bien non mais si
demain
eh bien mon dieu shabalin puisque vous
faites là grâce d'assister à ce point je
ne puis que m'incliner ce n'est pas un
geste qui devrait surprendre vos plus
lorsque vous demandez quelque chose dans
super sereine et bien dit mais bon j'ai
entendu ça que vous pourrez compter sur
moi
oui elle est prêt moi et me transmet son
souvenir le meilleur mes fils ah oui et
il grandit
oui la mode des collections oui c'est un
goût qu'il est aujourd'hui celui là oui
enfin il est encore un peu jeune fo qui
finit ses études d'abord on veut on
verra
[Musique]
moi j'étais maurice évidemment elle a
une voix d'or pour faire avant qu'on ne
sait pas qu'on l'appelle que dans le
même temps créé qui déploie par double
célèbre isabelle je ne savais pas mais
bon c'est qu'il est toujours habillé
comme un mousquetaire elle m'a chargé
les émeutiers pour toi résonneront mais
je suis pas du tout du tout tout a fait
d ma charmante son mari vit donc avoir
un point de vue là c'est différent ça
doit pas être drôle tous les jours
d'être le mari de d'artagnan non parce
que j'ai en fait oui ça tu n'es pas en
danger
en tout cas vous avez été charmant avec
l hippolyte est on ne peut plus galants
quand vous voulez vous savez être
délicieux tu passes du corps de garde au
grand siècle comme personne je te le dur
ça nous l'avons droit ici qu'aux mots
que tu connais mais si tu sors de la
famille on dirait toujours que tu
t'adresses à louis xiv
chère madame cher mada alors là tu es
formidable
d'abord je te fais à ma tête je n'aurais
jamais appelé louis xiv chère madame
edith ensuite voilà une femme charmante
qui me téléphonent avait beaucoup
d'insistance
on me demandait de faire les enchères à
la mairie tempo 109 rodez petit grenier
noir tu veux que j'engage j'ai accepté
poliment je pense à ma musique c'est
d'aller faire le pitre de risquer une
extinction de voix le lendemain mais
vous avez un très grand succès quand
vous faites les enchères hippolyte vous
êtes à vous tendre à vous être rigolo
comme toute l'année passée tout le monde
se tordait vous aurez le même succès
cette année tous les os minutie final 1
c'est ça laisse nous un moment nous
avons deux ou trois choses à nous dire
je parlais de quoi en tout cas que vous
discutez pas si toutefois nettement
je suis très calme excellente humeur je
vois pas pourquoi demi discuterions mais
oui quand vous voulez vous avez un
caractère honore notre charmant moi
aussi je suis très calme
je suis toujours d'ailleurs et je
voudrais justement profiter de ton calme
à toi pour régler la question tout à
l'heure telle question comment quelles
questions
thual pendant un quart d'heure et tu
décides de tu déclares que tu vas mettre
l'eau à la porte
et là-dessus intermède au téléphone et
quand je reprends la conversation entre
qui a tout de même de quoi intéresser un
tout petit peu tu me demande de quoi il
s'agit c'est fait pour aujourd'hui ce
temps là non pas en droit l'autre jour
ce tube qui a sauvé des vies
non j'ai pas changé d'avis j'ai changer
d'humeur maintenant ma décision est
prise je suis maître de moi je pense et
et tu te prépares année au cinéma
peut-être notre corps tout le pan
l'autre chaussée pluie et bien pas moi
si tu veux bien
ah mais oui mais oui justement tu vois
pas pourquoi tu détiendrait là dessus un
monopole
j'ai deux ou trois choses à te dirais tu
les entends drap et calmement le dégoûte
respectueuse monde je te dirai tout
d'abord que si tu avais des projets pour
ta soirée tu peux les mettre à exécution
sans attendre lolo pour le jeter dehors
parce que nous ne rentrera pas ce soir
il est parti en week end jusqu'à -10
week-end mais avec quelques amis sur la
mienne j'ai trouvé aussi inutile que lui
de provoquer sa part une scène de 20
minutes pour une autorisation
parfaitement normal à lui accorder
parfaitement normal pour nous ce qui
vient de se faire remercier la compagnie
d'assurance ou lever quand il n'y aurait
pas mis au pain et à l'eau dans sa
chambre n'est ce pas alors je trouvais
encore préférable de le savoir 24 heures
à la campagne qu en train de rouler dans
paris et d'aller de barran cinéma et
avec lui ce week-end le monsieur
avec son ami robert probablement c'est
bien qu'ils sont toujours ensemble
avec son ami robert était tu aimes
djassa d'anglais je te le dis aux jeunes
arrivent justement pas un rencontre et
ont un statut pourrait ainsi lever par
là que tu me fais peur sa salle comble
je te demande si tu ne sais pas
parfaitement depuis au moins deux ans
que l'eau long un ami qui s'appelle
robert avec lequel il est déjà parti
vingt fois en week end ou en vacances
évidemment je me suis alors pourquoi
trouve t extraordinaire que je te parle
de son ami robert et max tu de te dire
dans le blanc de l'oeil qui sont encore
aujourd'hui partis tous les deux en quoi
est ce une chose énorme de ma part
parfois puisque toutes les menaces il en
parlant plus je t'ai qu il part avec son
ami robert en vo je dois trouver cet
endroit parfait mais je te répète qu'il
y a deux ans que tu trouves normal
depuis deux ans je m'imaginais poste je
ne voulais pas pensé
voila voila tu ne voulais pas penser
seulement moi ça fait des années que je
te vois ne pas vouloir penser tu ne peux
pas penser non plus que tu as un autre
fils qui s'appelle roger qui a 17 ans et
carys 7 ans on a besoin d'un peu
d'argent
tu ne peux pas y penser parce que tu lui
en donne jamais et que tu n'es pas
surpris qu'ils n'en demandent pas tu le
blague à table sur sa fameuse comtesse
polonaise qui est devenu ici le grand
sujet de plaisanterie et tu ne peux pas
penser que roger et son hameau et qu'il
est entretenu par elle tu peux pas y
penser et tu va sauter en l'air
maintenant je te le dis bon projet la
mangue
et autres sont explosés lui tu te dis
non il me l'a pas dit je le comprends
c'est tout nous ne fermons pas les yeux
moi ce n'est pas la tête dans le sable
et ce conflit qui ne peut pas en être
autrement
par exemple même que j'élève mes enfants
je le dirige les habits jauge après
leurs études c'est entendu mais à 17 ans
on va au cinéma où s'achètent ses
premiers livres ses disques préférés ont
fumé
on a envie de connaître des femmes de
hrw au google fort justement quelle
femme tu le sais mieux que moi mais tu
sais aussi les dangers que peuvent
courir ces gosses avec le genre de femme
qu'on trouve quand on n'a pas assez
d'argent
toute image et le colon quand l'on
comprend autant non non tu comprends
parfaitement ce que je vais dire ballon
parfait va faire vraiment
réjouissons-nous elle couche avec la
comtesse le voile à préserver essayer de
la rue un petit coq d'or sous les impôts
point tenu par la comtesse avons tenu à
l'effort tu n'as pas comme ça ça arrange
tout prétendant parler plutôt non chaque
fois chacun tout allait bien à moi tu
m'as répondu par une boutade la pontaise
tu poses
mais si tu passes ton temps a plaisanté
à dire ddd gaudriole chaud tout ce qui
peut être sérieux et a tempêté juré sur
ce qui n'a aucun intérêt commercial pour
ça je te le dis comme je le pense parce
que tout à l'heure à propos de l'eau
l'eau que le toupet de mettre en avant
des principes et l'éducation que tu lui
avait donné l'un parfaitement
eh bien je te répondrais mois que
justement tu ne t'es pas occupé de leur
éducation ni alagna mais n'ont jamais
ils ne protestent pas parce qu alors
c'est moi qui mettrait en colère et pour
de vrai mais ce ne sera pas une colère
qui tombera comme par enchantement parce
que la baronne machin truc m'a
m'appellera au téléphone ça te le
garantis
aussi pour une fois je l'aurai
jamais jamais une telle charge et de ce
qui s'appelle une éducation jamais tu
n'es seulement à l'est par un de leurs
professeurs c'est c'était moi qui
m'offrait la corvée et leurs devoirs à
la maison c'était encore moins le soir
et dans la journée je reprise les
chaussettes
tu as deux grands principes et tu nous
as cent mille fois rebattu les oreilles
avec ton grand-père la magistrature et
tout ce qui s'ensuit seulement à table
tu ne parlait jamais de tes études à toi
que pour dire les blagues que tu faisais
ma tous et ses sinistres idiot et
emmerdeur qu'on appelle les agrégés pour
les imiter en faisant le clown pour
déclaré j'aimerais mieux crever la
gueule ouverte qu'appartenir à cette
race de cuistre tu imagines avec quel
sérieux il écoutait le lendemain leurs
professeurs tu parlais de ton service
était pour fulminer contre ces bande de
salopards et d'où je ne sais quoi qu'on
appelle les militaires avec encore
quelques imitations clownesque à l'appui
et ut révolte et ensuite quand l'on a
déclaré un jour qu'il se débrouillerait
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais qu'il
mettrait certainement jamais les pieds
dans une gaze et hop tu t'es révolté
tout est indigne et tu l'a traité de
tous tu as mis en avant la france
l'honneur tu as parlé de la décadence
des nouvelles générations
c'est le mot lui a compris que tu
pouvais toujours crié que tout ce que tu
disais n'avait aucun sens quand parce
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux quand vous
faites les pitres où les professeurs de
morale quand tu auras fini tu me prends
un signe
je pourrais t'en dire encore pour
longtemps car tu l'as vu comme moi
commencé à porter des débats que
ridicule et se coiffer quelquefois d'une
manière insensée
j'ai essayé de mon côté d'y faire
quelque chose j'ai obtenu une ou deux
fois un résultat
c'est peu mais au moins je ne prétends
pas être une éducatrice toi tu t'es mis
en colère tu l'a insultée il t'a
tranquillement braver et le lendemain tu
veux si celui qui n'y pensez plus tu
acceptais jusqu'à la prochaine colère
qui n'avait pas plus de portée que la
première voilà voilà ta fameuse
éducation si tu as besoin de se trouvera
aussi les yeux sur elle et voilà des
principes au crillon hurle au nom de ces
principes admirable mais mes charmes
ensuite chaque geste prouve que ne crois
pas qu'on ne leur accordent aucune
valeur ou parlent de la guerre comme
d'un devoir ce secret et aux tempêtes de
toute sa vie
en traitant d'imbéciles et de sallanches
qui voudront forcé à la faire on veut
mettre son fils à la porte parce qu'en
vertu de certains principes pour le cas
pour une ordure mais on fait des
courbettes et les salamalecs à la
baronne lesbiennes
alors non c'est un peu facile moi aussi
j'aimerais mieux que lolo souhaite un
garçon comme les autres
seulement voilà il l'est pas et nous ne
pouvons rien ni toi ni moi
et justement parce qu'il ne l'est pas il
est plus sensible plus fragile qu'un
autre sous ses airs de gros sous flux
je ne connaissais pas touche à un cheveu
de sa tête c'est tout ce que je voulais
dire le jour tu le mettras la porte moi
je suis prêt et je sais où j'irai il ya
déjà longtemps veut c voilà maintenant
que fixe et j'espère
les gars longtemps aussi que j'aurais dû
le faire c'est à cause des enfants
je suis là
[Applaudissements]
d'où sort tu dois pas qu'est ce que tu
as vraiment pose pas de question et je
suis tu t'en gueuler avec papa et 10
moment ça va mal pour le lot qu'est ce
qui lui est arrivé eh ben c'est tout à
fait par hasard remarque que j'ai
rencontré et kwakwa battue c'est robert
son amie il l'a plaqué mais ils avaient
rendez vous à la gare des invalides tout
à l'heure et ben oui et c'est un petit
copain qui est venu à sa place pour
remettre une lettre à lolo une lettre de
robert tu sais pas ce qu'il a fait ce
petit [ __ ] il est parti avec une femme
ce qu'il faut qu'elle soit ce qu'il faut
qu'elle soit gars et femmes pour faire
un coup pareil tu parles d'une vache mes
mails holloway t-il comment as tu sues
et ben justement je te dis ça a été un
hasard formidable moi j'avais déjeuné
rue du bac chez enfin chez la comtesse
de njawe cas et j'allais chez un copain
tout d'un coup dans la rue de grenelle
je vois arriver mon lolo en face de moi
comme un somnambule la figure pleine
dollars tout le monde le regard des
moyens voyait même pas j'arrête
il se met à sangloter sur mon épaule en
moi je savais plus où j'en étais tu
penses nous sommes rentrés dans un bar
et là il m'a montré la lettre de robert
toujours sans prononce il a tellement
ils chialent est alors je lui ai dit que
j'allais leur accompagné ici en taxi il
a aussi des épaules je vais proposer
d'aller chez chez la comtesse denis
arcas c'est une amie et il a pas marché
non plus finalement il y avait un hôtel
en face du bar il a été d'accord
alors je lui ai pris une chambre pour
qu'ils puissent avoir sa crise
tranquillement j'ai pas voulu téléphoner
tu comprends parce que enfin je crois
que si tu venais de trouver ça lui
ferait du bien
je me prépare bon ben je t'attends un
bon avec mon taxi
tiens-toi tomber sur papa si les mauvais
points
[Musique]
voilà on appliquera les fins de mois en
poste pour son robot et terrell et oui
préférait ça aussi ma mère suppose que
vous allez le trouver extrêmement dans
un paquet de lettres que je viens de
saisir dans la chambre de lolo on a tout
même le droit de connaître les
fréquentations de ses enfants et
liminaire n'oublions pas mal aux notes
malhonnête boucler ma grosse pomme
ma grosse nouilles mal alors voilà faut
savoir que l'artiste qui s'appelle
charge et qu'on appelle le lot nous fait
parler c'est encore cela pourtant qu'à
28 ans est terrifié dû sortir elle
mettait son chapeau et préparer son
petit sac qui sortent pour quoi faire
je ne sais pas je me dis seulement coup
de main je ne toucherai pas ici sur ce
toit le couchant c'est ce qu'il m'a dit
georges fut elle était très très près
s'il me dit je ne peux pas expliquer
maintenant
ne t'inquiète pas et elle va pas durer
les voilà enfin du nouveau ma femme des
couches est une honte je vais vous le
dire on va où elle est allée elle est
allé chez son amant l un est mort oui
j'en ai pas comme ça tout le temps je
vais essayer la fin
pas spécialement entend dire des
plaisanteries et elana non c'est elle
même qui m'a dit tout à l'heure
elle m'a parlé sur un ton qu'on n'avait
jamais employé avec moi et elle m'a fait
une scène d'ouverture n'ait pu voir en
me disant des choses dégueulasses
mais maintenant je comprends tout elle a
terminé en disant le jour où je
mentirais je sais ce qui est née et elle
a même ajouté ya longtemps que j'aurais
dû le faire et elle est allée elle avait
un amant nom de dieu entre chose que je
sais c'est un nom depuis des années
encore une chose que je n'avais pas
voulu voir
eh bien ma mère est maintenant vous tuer
bush en écrire sur votre fauteuil
cette fois alesi et regardez bien votre
genre au ruban d'honneur il en vaut la
peine
quand tu perds d'une tante et d'un
accroc vive la famille
[Musique]
tout va bien avait dit votre fini le
loup en béton jamais les pieds ici
madame pauline oui oui vous avez bien
qu'ils reviendront tous les deux jamais
vous le verrez ce que oui je vous
connais justement vous ne voulez pas
vous voir comme vous êtes vous êtes
charmant bon pour commencer le charbon
non je ne rentrerai pas ce soir en plus
j'ai mon rayon vert de mon côté
ma grosse conne ils sont terribles à cet
âge
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur j'ai fini je ferme la
fenêtre mais je m'en vais monter ta
arrêté j'ai oublié de remonter hier soir
et il doit être 10 heures par là bas je
dis venez à monsieur je vais regarder la
pendule de la cuisine
après oui monsieur avec madame madame
oui monsieur ben bella oui monsieur
madame est arrivé tout à l'heure avec
lolo qui est malade
lolo il est là aussi oui monsieur madame
la coucher mais monsieur est sorti de
bonheur aujourd'hui pour un dimanche
c'est pas sorti jory ben je savais pas
que monsieur avait été en voyage cette
nuit et monsieur à déjeuner déjeuner
merci mais vous dites que madame est
rentré tout à l'heure avec chambre avec
le niablé le charles colleoni des
plaines enfants et donc d'être de voyage
monsieur il n'avait pas d'idée ici ou
non plus hier soir jeudi à madame
commotion et là non je lui dis pas oui
madame est avec lolo ma main je veux
dire
alex charles ça ne me vient pas monsieur
bah non de l'apli charme est au rendez
vous rappeler c'est un homme non mais je
ne sais pas mais c'est quoi
et je veux dire je ne sais pas pourquoi
ça ne vient pas mais je les connais trop
petit je crois pas mais tout compte fait
nombre de rangées pas madame d'état
madame gombert je vais l'avoir d'abord
séduite à sa toilette j'y fais monsieur
est ce que c'est encore que d'histoires
la malade de poids et c'est est ce qu'il
ramène à 10 heures du matin
s'il a encore fait chute comme conneries
c'est lui là qu'est ce que je vais
apprendre bol devant le jour où la
machine à fabriquer les emmerdements
s'arrêtera de tourner on fera plaisir je
commence un bon match d'où sortez vous
vous faites des tours pendables
où avez vous passé la nuit vous avez
vous écrit très inquiète quand et bien
tout à l'heure maintenant quand elle est
rentrée d'autant plus qu'elle a ramené
lolo malades
la pauvre chérie elle se fait un sang
d'encre et leur lot longue je ne sais
pas gérer cela dit qu'il n'était pas
bien du tout qu'elle avait veillé toute
la nuit et où ça roule à travailler sait
toujours pas où il a passé la nuit
bousculé par hippolyte on m'a laissé
tout seul ici je vais là t'es plein de
soucis j'ai très mal dormi chez moi en
plus j'ai pas d'armes ici ou là aussi le
100 m pourquoi drôlement charmant promet
m commandite vous vous étiez seule
rangée étaient ici j'espère il est
rentré ce matin il n'est pas rentré du
tout
parents très vite et je n'en sais rien
moi je ne sais pas ce qui vous a pris à
tous est vide poche est d'or fais ça se
passe
j'espère que vous allez me l'apprendre
ya 10 et les routes pour coucher lolo
depuis je cherche à me parler
roger balan hier soir il est en train de
dîner avec moi je lui ai appris que vous
ne vous seriez pas ici vous m'aviez
quitté en me prévenant n'est ce pas
alors il m'a dit après le dîner puisque
papa n'est pas là cette ville d'anvers
aller au cinéma et tu ferais bien de te
coucher parce que je rentrerai peut-être
un peu tard oui les connaissez
sceptiques il faut tirer
voilà comment je suis resté tout seul
parfois bravo le ciel continue nous
allons à temps complet du super vous
allez manger faire bien ah oui j'espère
bien que gégé va rentrer et où peut-il
se promener comme ça
cinéma ferme à minuit et il est 10h30
vous avez l'envié 10h30 ce mépris à la
radio hier soir 10h30 du monsieur à
demander leur exacte il est 10 heures
juste je les prises au plancher des 10
ce matin à 10h30 a pas d'art se trompent
je ne me trompe pas je vous hais la
radio hier soir l'ours et l'amant de
madame qui est qu'ils avancent moi j'ai
plus ou klouchi ce matin mais non maman
tu n'avances pas une marche très très
bien
c'était la montre de ma mère elle n'a
jamais ni retardée n'est avancée alors
c'est madame qui a mal entendu à la
radio fait pas du tout les jeunes y
jetteraient viendra entendu vous pouvez
vous encore fallait l'abattre
alors si la radio qui s'est trompé mais
la radio ne peut pas se tromper de
bollywood y mélanger les deux heures dix
sept exactement
alors c'est le téléphone qui se trompe
c'est tout de même plus téléphonie la
radio pourrait bien se mettre d'accord
vous mamour et qu'ils sont ridicules
tous les braves le dit qu'il veut se
mettre au milieu avec son clocher
bonbons ma mère cette ville internet
d'honneur c'est bien ça vaut prochain à
fouetter
alors vous ne savez pas ce cash à vous
ne savez pas plus les reins premier
titre à vous écouter ou thérèse a passé
la nuit ni comment la retrouver son fils
savez vous dis mon petit liste est
devenu roger vous voyez qu'il a pu lui
arriver un accident il faudrait les
habitués tout de même à nous dire un peu
où ils vont c'est très ennuyeux je vais
savoir à ma mère désormais sur ce
chapitre là où abbas fait avant profit
moi j'ai décidé de me désintéresser de
la question j'ai jamais su élever mes
enfants je suis un clown
quand je vais perdre leur faire
l'observation de prendre une décision
qui les concerne c'est exactement comme
tu chantes et la grand messe en musique
résultat zéro que je parle au nom cet
effectif ici on se foutrait part de
seulement chez je revenais dans ma
famille politique mais non intérêt c'est
beau alors filialiser plus de conneries
je ferme la boutique
tu connais tout à terre je sais jamais
te dire des baux brillant quand il
s'agit de choses sérieuses et mme
emporté contre skill aucune importance
c'est votre fille qui tient le pompon
les 10es palais à ces messieurs le
langage tous on vient par conséquent ne
me posez plus de questions sur eux voyez
la main vous êtes bien hervé poly ou
n'est pas un jeu j'ai pas besoin d'être
en jeu pour être nerveux mais bon
j'étais à 300 me met très bien je vous
remercie
ne pas dire vous est envoyé en l'air que
vous disiez récoltera mont royal est il
avait dit ça pour plaisanter c'est une
expression qui ne signifie rien fait
heureusement le jour où j'aurai envie de
m'envoyer en l'air je le ferai et ça ne
traînera peut-être pas au train où vont
les choses
alors trêve n'a toujours pas dit où elle
allait et vous le soupçon mais pas vous
voulez le pas de vis des lots plus c'est
pas que son ami et moi j'ai dit oui
c'était même elle même qui l'a dit hier
soir je voulais déjà bon ça qui tournait
à paris toute famille qui ait souillé
savoir police continue n'est pas écouter
ce genre de questions je vais faire ma
toilette vous expliquerez avec thérèse
justement comment les lolos qu'est-ce
qu'il a bon jour il est malade
bonjour ne nous parlait pas ensemble et
ne me posais pas de questions en même
temps vous serez bien gentil et puis ne
laissez pas cette porte ouverte on vous
entendre sa chambre mais je voudrais
bien savoir
il m'a là c'est un accident il a tu
retrouvé écoute maman il n'est pas
malade et ça n'est pas un accident qui
impliquerait mieux un peu plus tard soit
gentil va finir ta toilettes laisse-le
se reposer sur tout et fais-moi couleurs
dont on s'en va vers le second morceau
pour je vous laisse j'ai dit à léonie de
me préparais une tasse de thé dit lui de
me l'apporté si elle est prête ou
risquer cool et aubin mais nous
discutons pas sur tout ça je n'en ai pas
besoin de lui ne soyez pas dire vous
tu peux cependant de données telles que
mon explication tu te prends plaisir ou
avez vous passé la nuit
comment tu retrouvé charles qui était
parti en week-end il n'est pas parti en
week-end soit je te remercie j'avais
compris il n'est pas parti en week end
et son ami l'a quittée voilà ce que ça
veut dire son ami l'a quitté ça veut
dire son avis la quitte et tu ne sais
pas ce que c'est qu'une rupture mais
bien voilà
et depuis depuis hier après midi je suis
au près d'une épave d'un pouf petit qui
sanglotait qui souffrent tout ce qu'on
peut souffrir c'est par roger que
j'étais prévenue je suis parti tout de
suite j'ai préféré ne pas mettre au
courant à ce moment là c'était inutile
non merci
donc c'est vrai alors ça je me lancerai
que la tour eiffel et le panthéon
changer de place cette nuit je ne
tomberai pas le plus aux réalités madame
non
non je ne tomberai comme nous il est
dans un état où le pauvre maroc c'est
formidable quand même rapidement mais
des trottoirs à nous raconter
tranquillement que notre fils a été
plaquée par son ami et entendre dire le
plus simplement du monde
le pauvre petit dans un état fou comme
s'il s'agissait de l'histoire tout
naturellement jugé naturel ou pas moi je
ne vois qu'une chose c'est que ce petit
souffre comme nous n'avons peut-être
jamais souffert ni toi ni moi
heureusement pour lui aussi à décrocher
le cocotier il inaugure le mal d'amour
jusqu'à lui personne n'a connu ça si tu
l'avais veillé toute la nuit tu n'aurais
pas envie de plaisanter statut fond mais
de quoi formidable tu ne comprends pas
ce que c'est qu'un drame et tu ne sais
pas que cet âge là ce genre de leur
emprise de la tragédie lolo et mais que
veux tu que je te dise il aimait d'amour
je m'en suis aperçu depuis et il réagit
comme comme n'importe qui dans ses rangs
comme n'importe qui mais le trust bank
est une forme d'une année après qu'il
soit comme une femme comme une bête
c'est plutôt comme une bête d'ailleurs
une seule chose compte sa douleur et et
l'état dans lequel il est le moyen pour
l'état dans le télé à parce qu'il n'ya
pas autre chose à boire
il aimait d'amour a annoncé attendre une
mère de dieu ça dans le blanc de l'oeil
à pourquoi du petit ami robert sauf et
suivront deux chapeaux pas retenu ce
serait pareil s'il souffrait à cause
d'une flamme et ça n'arrangerait serait
pas dans l'état alors ressemble à toi et
moi face à face parce que le petit ami
robert à attaquer votre fils ne dépasse
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
tu ne vois que ça toi la cmc important
et nous devons nous acquitter
reconnaître que nous n'y pouvons rien et
en parler encore une fois avec l'air
sérieux et embêter des parents dont la
vie vient de voir ses fiançailles
rompues alors qu'il s'agit je te dis il
ya quand même des trucs qui vous dépasse
s'il n'y avait pas ce drame tu ne serais
pas pris compte en espère qu est ce que
tu veux dire s'il filait le parfait
amour ça ne te plairait bada vente en
gros soit encore pu alors tu vois tu
n'as plus qu'à te réjouir que les choses
et m'a tourné au fond tu n'as aucune
raison d'être en colère bien sûr robin
on sais rien moi un ami à lui tu ne
connais pas tous les garçons avec qui il
sort tout moi non plus tout ce que je
sais c'est qu'il a quitté lolo pour une
femme
sauf si tu prends mes lèvres je compose
je la situe était son père tu te réjouir
et de le voir rentrer dans le bon chemin
avec son père ça me fait tomber sur le
manga je le vois d'ici et peut-être
aussi recommandable que j'entends ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup a cédé joliment à
la désordre est à quelque chose pour
balayer tout ça allez hop fait ma place
est de toute cette saloperie un peu
d'air à bon dieu tu parles de qui dit
père fille je m'en fous tous dans le
même panier allons devoir apprendre à
vivre whatsapp alors je vais au parc
purée ça mais pour le moment assieds toi
tu veux pas plaisir n'ai pas dormi cette
nuit ça me fatigue de doit retourner à
bastien à propos
parlons-en un peu de cette pluie ou la
tue pas c'est que l'open manotel rue de
grenelle où j'ai retrouvé l'eau l'eau
que j'y suis resté avec lui quand j'ai
vu où il en est mais qu'est ce qu'il
faisait dans cet hôtel coûteux voudrait
bien ne pas subir maintenant à
l'intérieur pour moi je voudrais bien
sans se fatiguer davantage savoir celle
qui a passé la nuit avec ton fils si tu
ne vois pas d'inconvénient d'acheter le
titre je ne marche pas comment tu ne
marche pas tu ne crois pas ce que je
t'ai dit nom figure toi je te remercie
ya pas de quoi hier tu m'a dit si tu
pars tu es un jour tu savais chez
thierry oui je me l'a dit oui qu'est-ce
que ça sinon coups bas pour maintenant
papa même temps et est ressorti à
l'inquiétude laisse entendre avec clarté
que tu as un amant
même si tu t'en fais un sac de voyage à
la matu pas s'améliore et que je te
demande maintenant où tu as passé cette
fille je n'ai pas besoin de réponses
mais lors du bois tout de suite que je
suis en surnombre ainsi incapable d'être
un nid père et mari on se demande ce que
j'attends pour m'en aller du bon pied
bon oeil
il montre personnes peuvent supporter
ici que le sucre copie lui disant tu dis
le moi je suis pas plus
je voudrais bien que le tiercé
malheureusement pas vrai tu préfère
toujours la version de l'hôtel hier qui
va cependant dit cette phrase ça le jour
je partirai je sais ce qui allait et a
même ajouté ya longtemps que j'aurais dû
le faire
est-ce vrai ou non oui tu pensé à
quelqu'un de précis redisant sa wii à
qui attendent à man à celui qui pourrait
l'être c'est-à-dire donc un ami à moi
naturellement
henry mon cousin encore mieux henry pour
et et on ne manque plus qu'un depuis le
jour où tu me l'a conseillé
moi j'étais conseiller un jour de
prendre au rythme à mort
tu m'a même dit il sera parfait pour toi
il te fait la cour chaque fois qu'il se
voit en recto faisait la cour
c'est toi tu vas ouvert les yeux mais je
savais déjà qu'il me plaisait que tu
leur lancée comme tu dis le lendemain
parce que j'aurais ajouté cette petite
phrase oui parce que tu étais allé un
peu trop loin ce soir là et parce que
j'en pouvais plus est devenu ton nom
il m'a fallu de sérieuses raisons pour y
résister je te rassure il n'est pas
devenu mon amant lorsque j'ai compris
dans ce cas là je ne supporterai plus de
venir ici d'habiter avec toi et que je
serai obligé de t'abandonner les enfants
quand il a compris il m'a offert alors
le plus naturellement du monde de venir
me réfugier chez lui quand je voudrais
si un jour tu me rendes l existence trop
peu dieuze le pas pressé il attend son
heure
on attend le jour où tu te décideras
mais non de dieu le fasse mal t-il celui
là aurait été capable de voir justement
des résistances aux dieux alors je n'ai
plus qu'à me demander si tu l'as fait
exprès je t'ai rendu l'existence odieuse
moi tu t'en ai jamais aperçu non pour
moi comme tout pour tes fils ski jane tu
ne veux pas le voir
et si je t'ai dit que moi j'ai lutté
contre ce qui aurait pu être un amour
pour avoir la force de continuer à vivre
ici à cause des enfants
si je te dis que tu m'as tué de cris de
pacification et de grossièreté pendant
20 ans et que pendant un temps au pus
presque chaque soir envie de tout
envoyer promener et toi maman la maison
les gosses tu me diras encore tu n'en
savez rien tu n'avais pas vu et bien
tant pis mais puisque maintenant tu veux
tout apprendre sache le oui hier après
la scène que nous avons eue quand j'ai
su ce qui était arrivé à lolo
j'ai fait un sac et j'ai décidé d'aller
me réfugier cette nuit chez henri et je
te jure bien que cette fois c'était dans
ses bras je comptais passer cette nuit
là tu l'a échappé belle et ses talents
l'eau tu le dois
dans l'état où je les ai vus n'a pu été
question de rien pas même de quitter cet
open
sans lui tu ne l'avait pas volé c'est
trop facile de toujours faire l'autruche
et de prendre ensuite les red stone et
ou de tempêter dans tous les coins parce
qu'on n'avait pas voulu voir ça
n'arrange rien
il fallait voir vous avez des yeux vo si
les hommes
si vous ne voulez pas vous aussi à dire
tant pis tu n'avais que ce que tu
méritais
au fond c'est ma faute j'ai c'est
peut-être exprimera au fisc et une passe
et quand même en vigueur cet égard c'est
si pour quelque chose dans le fait je ne
sais pas moi non plus je suis pour rien
c'est pourtant nous bien nous deux qui
l'avons fait justement symbole demandait
si tu permets
voilà là dessus du n'a vraiment pas
besoin de se creuser la tête il estoit
de garantie jamais personne dans ma
famille je te le garantis aussi et une
humeur centre nature faire ça viendrait
tong hon tai fai que je sais pas
autorité
mais toujours eu la dent foulée avaient
toutes façons ce métier du croupion mais
celui-ci lui ça n'a pas j'avais
personnes de mon côté il n'y a pas qu'en
foot et un bouchon à celle là [ __ ] je
ne crie pas pourtant si tu plies la
porte et où jean pierré 6 veut même plus
ouvrir cette maison ben voilà on nous en
savons
voilà notre maire de tende en région il
est probable que je ne suis qu'un
imbécile non seulement à m'emporter a
parlé comme un garde d'écurie à faire le
malheur de tous ceux qui m'entourent
depuis 20 ans je n'ai vu qu'un seul
souci celui de gagner le pot vous élever
correctement toujours torturé par cette
idée que vous puissiez me reprocher un
jour sur ce point la plus petite est de
dix ans j'ai toujours eu à débattre tout
seul je n'avais pas fait le très
brillantes études mais le choix varié
j'évite tout en amour propre
c'est-à-dire coûte que coûte
haro convenable travailler comme un
[ __ ] le soir je rentrais fatigué énervé
par ma préoccupation de la journée
maîtrisé sans doute pas mais n'est ni
pareil j'ai jamais su que vous rendre la
vie en dieu à tous et que votre mère a
été pleinement la plus mauvaise des
femmes vous ne m'aimez pas et elle même
plus tard est aussi que tout ça me crève
les yeux depuis longtemps
jusqu'ici pas voulu le voir maintenant
tout est clair
toi chamond pour petit tu ne peux rien
au fond le cap ratu les catégories
d'hommes que je ne peux pas comprendre
je ne peux pas supporter c'est plus fort
que moi je ne fais pas ça ne se discute
pas malheur veut que soit mon fils et
que tous nous dresse les uns contre les
autres c'est ton père et nous ne sommes
pas de la même famille c'est ta mère
parle de trajet dit on va la lui je
voudrais tu admettre comme tu es on va
aux cités mais j'ai envie de te gifle et
chaque fois que tu passes à côté de moi
tu souffres en ce moment c'est comment
aussi je le soufre en même temps
pourquoi je peux te dire ces quelques
mots sur un ton que tu me connais guère
de ma part j'ai aimé ta mère
bien que je laime toujours mal de mes
comportements à mes collègues oui je
l'aimais elle est ma femme
en ce moment mon petit je suis plus près
de toi
alors voici je remettrai venthône
emmerdes en jean qu'elle m'a confié je
ferai en outre à votre mère des
versements réguliers que vous ne
manquerez de rien ici moi je m'en vais
vivre nos pour tous se mettent également
plus que je vous ai tous rendus si
malheureux faux bond pardon
attila oui bonjour pas maman est là
aussi
oui à elle est rentrée avec lolo ouais
ouais tu sortais propos tu rentres toi
si je comprends bien
oui c'est à dire et à dire pour à turin
oui c'est parce que tu savais que nous
te met en émoi le coup je regarde si
c'est depuis que tu a jugé bon d'en
faire autant oui si j'avais été là tu
sais très bien que sa rentrée a
forcément alors c'est idiot de ta part
tu ne trouves pas oui bien sûr situe
alors que gide ou tu fais quelque chose
en sachant très bien que ni thèmes et
animale et autorisions et en sachant
aussi que nous la prendrons tous les
deux c'est bien ça oui alors alors si
maintenant je me fichais te
reconnaîtrais que j'ai raison que tu
mérite une punition dakwar accord
accroîtra dire le contraire veux pas me
fâcher ni te punir veux te parler
calmement de quelque chose d'important à
moi à toi que la nage on peut te parler
je prouvais 7 puis que tu peux être
idiot mais qu'il est plus un nourrisson
assieds-toi projet je ne te demande pas
où tu as passé la nuit je le sais cet
acompte est ce pas je te demande même
pas de me dire oui je le sais alors
voici j'ai remarqué une chose c'est que
tu ne me demande jamais d'argent et ta
mère m'a dit que tu lui en demandait pas
non plus pourtant tu fumes tu vas cinéma
en dehors des heures de cours
du moins j'espère que c'est en dehors tu
fumes avec a forcément des freins alors
ou prends tu ton argent si ce n' ya qu'
mandat enfin la comtesse la comtesse oui
m'attendais pas à ce que tu m'as vous ça
avec cette désinvolture
pourquoi parce que ça porte un nom qui
fait rentrer au pays mais est les
premiers à la 22e 22 heures
elle s'est mariée à 16 ans et demi son
mari situé ya trois ans dans une chute
de cheval elle a hérité tout frais de la
famille bettencourt est elle bien sûr et
il te donne de l'argent mais jusqu'où je
pourrais avec elle pour qu'elle me donne
de l'argent tu couches avec elle parce
qu'elle me plaît et elle elle me dit
qu'elle ait eu un peu ouais et dickens
trouve rigolo et elle te donne de
l'argent parce que le tout venant en bas
c'est plutôt parce qu'ils voient que
j'en ai pas battu l'accès pourquoi pas
ça lui coûte rien elle est plein aux as
au contraire à hoëdic ça j'aimerais si
je refusais d'ailleurs j'ai pas essayé
bon bah dorénavant tu demanderas de
l'argent à ta mère te donnera ce qu'il
te four et pour commencer
tiens mon petit pour la 100 mille fois
t'es bien gentil papa mais qu'est ce que
tu veux que je fasse avec 5000 francs
mais il semble que tu peux encore te
payer deux ou trois séances de cinéma
quelques paquets de cigarettes non bien
sûr mais ça sert à rien je t'assure 5000
francs ça peut faire plaisir à maman
pour acheter du rouge à lèvres ou pour
aller chez son coiffeur jeu sera bien
mieux c'est pour ça que je te demande
jamais rien tout ce que sonia me donne
c'est autant d'économies pour ici je
n'ai jamais demandé le mouvement ne
pratique jamais gauguin seule personne
c'est bien mais je n'accepterai pas plus
de roubaix où le polonais dalibot
ménages en du cnc par gentillesse et
parce qu'elles sont mais moi je m'en
fous de sa gentillesse et je le foot
elle s'en foutent pas reçu le marché à
tatort papa l'autre jour j'ai une idée
justement pour le lot demandé à sonia
qu'elle met du fric pour lui dans un
magasin en magasin de quoi ma de couture
parbleu une boutique où il sera chez lui
où il confectionnerait ses modèles du
moi j'aime beaucoup ton frère va
s'installer ton couture eu un pourquoi
pas il fait des trucs épatant sonia est
d'accord elle m'a dit que pour l'eau
lors et fera tout ce qu'on voudrait
plusieurs millions si c'est utile plus
remuant mais je te dis si tu ne mets pas
t'en ai dit que l'argent c'est fait pour
s'en servir et moi quand j'aurai mis au
point mon invention elle donnera ce
qu'il faut pour prendre un brevet bon
mais pour commencer que voilà dix mille
fort et tu va me faire plaisir de
laisser ta contestant qui va cesser de
l'avoir c'est toi que ça dépend car tu
imagine assez bien sans vouloir te faire
de belles montées que tu allais pas que
toi dans sa vie bah bien sûr à la
poitrine
ah bon tu le sais je le sais bien sûr
que je le sais je peux quand même pas
l'occuper à moi tout ça mais je m'en
fous tout un fond oui ça me gêne pas et
puis c'est moi qui ai préfet elle te le
dis et je le crois pas je lui demandais
rien moi si elle le dit c'est que c'est
vrai et je vois pas pourquoi ce serait
vrai d'ailleurs parce que tout ce qui me
touche c'est sacré tout ce que touche
ouais moment lolo toi moi aussi je suis
sacré toi tiens si tu avais besoin de
fric pour tes affaires je suis sûr qu'à
temps passe réellement de dredd alors je
vais pas tout vous faire au total et
enfin la ponote de cette foison mais
jamais donné cette époque repique et à
samia non bien sûr aller piquer mais
elle est gentil comme tout si tu la
connais ça l'est peut se dire ils font
ne parle plus des peut tu as non je
t'assure papa ça me gêne
alors ça c'est le con ça te gêne quand
c'est moi et venant d'elle ça te gêne
quoi va bien sur elle et moi on s'aime
quoi c'est pas pareil tu es là tu vois
c'est maintenant que tu rentres ce
prétexte que tu es trop plein du mois
mais tient ici cette nuit mamans
viennent me raconter ça allait filmé
dans sa chambre et et surtout ne pas
plutôt frère dans papa tu m'as vrac on
peut tout de même pas mettre 5 alors
lentement vers quoi
pourquoi la jif les invités de fautes et
la pollution sont ni tumulte et idiote
naturellement on était en train de me
raisonner avec de l'argent au bout des
doigts
ben oui tu lui donner de l'argent
ah oui oui j'ai trouvé raisonnable ce
que tu disais hier tu te lèves et tu le
gip
c'est idiot encore une fois mais je suis
énervé tu comprends pas cet idiot c'est
à moi de gagner d'autres joueront cette
fois c'est bon on se fâche pas c'est un
expert a distribué les bars moi je
renonce si je m'étais permis d'envoyer
cette gifle sera entendu en concert on
aurait abattu les oreilles pendant dix
ans j'ai rangé
lorsque vous avez bien fait là je vous
approuve pleinement
il faut que ces petits et de temps en
temps on rappelle à l'ordre
il s'en souviendra je vous félicite de
ces éléments
pourrais je vous rend cette justice
hippolyte que vous les avez pour ainsi
dire jamais soufflé vous créiez un peu
souvent c'est en tant que vous êtes un
violent vous ne pouvez rien et vous
parlez grand mais vous êtes dans le fond
une excellente air et vous aimez
beaucoup vos fils vous ne les avez
jamais maltraité
aujourd'hui vous avez bien fait mon
petit mais certaines circonstances où il
ne faut pas les rater
moi j'ai une quatre frères je sais ce
qu'il en est mon père était le meilleur
homme du monde
il n'empêche que je les rues giflé mon
frère alpha le jour même où alpha il a
eu 19 ans et jamais de sa vie mon père
m'avait la même veine la vie la main sur
local de nous mais ce jour là
alfred lui avait manqué sept gars jouent
toujours que lui n'a pas manqué malgré
ses 19 ans il l'attrapé plein de blagues
comme il n'en avait jamais reçue une
bravade frais qu'est-ce qu'il a raflé le
bronze
je ne sais plus je crois un trou qu'il
s'était laissé à quelques bêtises avec
la femme de chambre avec la femme de
chambre elle ferait peser dessus on vous
savez
ces lois tout ça j'avais 14 ans c'était
à la campagne c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre
je sais qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose à l'office où la ferme je ne me
rappelle pas très bien il est tout petit
valet de ferme que mon père ne pouvait
pas supporter et il voudrait bien être
pour quelque chose lui aussi dans cette
histoire de femme de chambre
carreman pour la renvoyer le jour même
je m'appelle on va le faire
alfred saluer ses côtés
lauriane monsieur je voulais dire à
monsieur que collet vient de sonner la
porte d'entrée aussi et qu'il est 10h45
et alors et alors la pendule de la
cuisine va bien bon c'est un beau jour
pendant trois tout de suite monsieur je
le fais pas le tour si monsieur permet à
votre aise ce n'est pas si monsieur
c'est monsieur henry il a demandé qui
monsieur était là j'ai dit oui
j'adorerais me fait homme sinon qu'est
ce qui t'a mail alors mon vieux tu es
content c'est super content bon tu ne
vas pas continuer à faire la tête je
veux une tête - peut-être de quoi le
captur juste et bien mais du succès
d'office succès comment vous n'êtes pas
au courant courant de quoi mais mon
vieux ton fils s'est couvert de gloire
charles il a remporté hier soir au
palais de chaillot le premier grand prix
des mannequins de paris premier vingt
mille francs devant une mangue yeux jean
charles robert ne le saviez pas ça du
tout et ben voila je te la prend et se
félicitent et remercient étudie à un
prix de 20 mille fois nouveau
naturellement 2 millions en france hier
à nouveau deux millions de vous annonce
rien
charles a remporté un prix non d'un
point de presse par 20 millions d'abord
tu ne trouves le je ne sais plus ce que
je dis vingt mille francs
charles a remporté le prix d'1 2 million
oui anciens oui merci
après quoi et bien le grand prix d'un
concours ouvert à tous les grands
couturiers pour la semaine de paris un
concours de petits mannequins publié par
des métis des décorateurs c'est charles
qui a remporté le grand prix
oui tu ne savais pas qu'il avait
présenté les deux pièces sont en cours
et ben voila je t'apprends leur issue je
comprends pas tu dis un concours ouvert
à tous les genres couturier oui et
couturiers et décorateurs couture et
chanel les amateurs étaient admis au
départ il devait passer une évidente
mans pour accéder au concours final ton
fils avait réussi cette épreuve par la
toux est celui qui a remporté la finale
devant tous les grands couturiers s y
était hier soir au palais de chaillot
oui premier grand prix charles barkley
on a cherché partout le triomphateur son
absence a doublé son succès et on l'a
clamé cimade qui ont été exposés sur la
table du jury je les ai vus à ce qu'il a
fait est adorable
il est là il faut bien non c'est ça le
bon tu n'en revient pas je m'attendais
pas je la vois pas ce genre de louvain
mais ce n'est d'ailleurs pas totalement
c'est ça que j'ai faits assure ce matin
moi j'étais persuadé que vous étiez au
courant non si je suis venu c'est pour
te parler d'une proposition qui m'a été
faite hier précisément à il faut battre
le fer quand il est chaud n'est ce pas
composition veillée de temps en temps
comme ça des espèces de mire acte des
coïncidences aux surprenantes qu'il ne
faut pas négliger
et c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu tout voir
tout de suite non c'était la paille les
receveurs avec un ami qui vient de
reprendre à son compte une petite maison
de couture et qui cherchent un un
créateur de mode elle pour relancer
cette maison tombé assez bas mais il
cherche ton fils quoi il me parlait de
ça je venais de lui dire que j'avais
dans ma famille même un jeune garçon
enfin je lui avais parlé de charles et
là-dessus ont lieu les résultats du
concours et qui remporte le grand prix
le même charme
at je n'ai pas besoin de te dire que les
éloges que j'aurai de fer sur son compte
on peut tout à coup une certaine valeur
alors voila voila mon ami est d'accord
et c'est ce que je viens te dire comment
d'accord si tu envisages cette situation
pour ton fils il est prêt à offrir une
association je connais marc mathis est
un homme sérieux qui s'intéresse à une
affaire c'est après l'avoir étudié
longuement on peut être tranquille avait
créé voilà il ne te reste plus qu'à
réfléchir mais vu le succès de ton fils
hier soir quel moyen de lui faire une
situation de premier plan mme bonds bon
maintenant il ya autre chose
ma relatifs lui a remis 50 millions dans
cette affaire il n'en voudra encore 20
il les trouvera je suis tranquille mais
je te pose la question de sa part si tu
pouvais toi même apporté ce capital la
position dont vie serait très différente
ce serait alors une véritable
association 20 millions aussi
naturellement oui à l'âge est compris
il est tombé sur la tête on a même raté
20 millions nouveaux titres et où je te
pose la question n'a pas jeté l'épongé
réponse aux hôtels espèces d'hésitation
je suis pas la banque de france
n'étaient pas les chercher d'autant que
charles
on a déjà gagné deux on peut trouver des
gens heureux de commanditer un débutant
le grand prix qu'il vient de remporter
dans l'aura des crédits à charles et
marratier est abusé d'une garantie mais
je te répète la position de charles
serait indifférente
si c'est lui qui apporte cet argent ou
or ceux de la rue
mais voilà mon vieux je ne te dis pas
plus réfléchis tu as mangé mes robes
téléphone sic envisage de donner suite
appelle-moi maladie est en 48 heures de
toute façon mais je te dis je ne crois
pas qu'une chance se présente du foie on
se favorablement envers ces îles très
heureux pour toi et et pour thérèse je
te félicite et tu vois que tout peut
s'arranger au fond et que tu n'es pas
aussi mauvais pour que ça ait obligé non
mais c'est vrai moi moi tu me fais rire
si tu veux le savoir
je te fait rire ah oui tu me fais rire
quand tu fais le lion la caf continue
enrichi entre intérêt énorme commencer
un prix avec vos animaux pour un jeu
fait l'autruche pour toi c'est le lions
club nous [ __ ] la paix votre ménage ou
se tenir l'iphone t'énerve pas tout je
te quitte
dis donc je ne dérange personne bon
alors qu'il me de mappage notre époque
non à propos tu ne t'es mari toujours
pas toi quoi pourquoi à propos non c'est
ma belle-mère qui chaque fois que je
vois me demande si tu ne te marie pas
bientôt à et bien dis lui que non tu
n'as pas encore trouvé la femme idéale
voilà tu attends moi je dis tu l'attends
commencé sa famille l'attend pas trouve
à chaque réponse
[Musique]
quand fred douchet mois du lion voilà
l'histoire qu'est ce qui est allé encore
fabriquer des poupées celui là et ils
viennent 2 millions avec une
couillonnade de ce coup là c'est
vraiment la peine est ce qu'on veut la
paillasse à vendre toute la journée les
appareils de chauffage on vous colle
deux mignons et apprenez grand prix je
demande un peu parce qu'un gamin est
allé torti et l'europe sont sur des
poupées non non ne collait pas non on ne
dit pas assez nous vivons vraiment une
époque de fou et pendant ce temps-là
effet la dame aux camélias et meurt
d'amour un soliste android au g8 en
train de râler à cause de ça gicle
angers monsieur monsieur cityflo les
fleurs c'est pour naulleau les fleurs
pour le lot tu m'appeler ma part oui je
viens d'apprendre l'histoire à tomber la
lune il paraît que ton frère a remporté
hier soir un concours de mannequins
reprenait de chaillot les mannequins
pareil que ça non 2 millions 5,2
millions prix de cancer a naturellement
à bon temps faire remporter un prix de 2
millions formidable
je savais qu'il était présenté ce
concours oui ils avaient été reçus aux
éliminatoires ya quinze jours
pas bon tu étais au pouvoir ouais il
avait demandé qu'on se le dise pas avant
très touché
quand il voulait sûrement de faire une
surprise s'il avait un prix et il a une
premiers jalons de ce mois
t'es pas content content content oui oui
je suis content mais doucement minutes
je dois dit citant sybarites de frais
pas s'imaginer que c'est arrivé tel que
je le connais va se prendre pour un
parent ben écoute justement c'est arrive
moi quoi qu'est-ce que tu arrives et ben
je sais pas moi 2 millions d'abord c'est
toujours ça et puis ça peut être
formidable pour le droit aux médias
formidable vous n'avez jamais ce mot là
à la bouche for media ce qui est
formidable c'est la connerie des gens
qui mettent 2 millions êtes en cours de
poupet ça oui c'est formidable le ponton
ferait rentrer nous obtenons en vaste et
trop difficile ne sais pas je réfléchis
je me pose la question je voudrais être
sûr que tout compte fait ce qui arrive à
ton frère vous vraiment appel de se
réjouir si va pas avoir la tête
complètement tourné sous prétexte que le
jury de la fougue de colère reprenez
donc bon
tous les grands couturiers de paris et
est admis à ce concours comment est ce
qu'on ferait qu'à remporter le prix oui
j'en sais rien moi c'est toi qui me la
prend et c'est au rythme l'annoncé est
bas alors tu vois je vois pas tout et
c'est vrai je te dis pas que ça n'est
pas vrai celui que tu as compris aussi
tu l'histoire 1 voix semblant mais
puisqu'elle evra liste qu'elle est vrai
est encore plus invraisemblable des
fleurs encore de faire bientôt 66 da
graca la salle
or
allô oui c'est ici monsieur oui c'est
moi même monsieur le rt oui une
interview 1 ce matin ça me paraît un peu
difficile disons plutôt après que dès
jeudi si vous voulez bien oui c'est ça à
deux heures par exemple avec un camion
de son cassoulet qui fasse d'un camion
de saut à la radio la radio ou même les
cieux oui mais d'abord et maintenant
deux heures précises par 34 34 rue de
saint pée au deuxième étage je vous
salue le rdf longtemps je viens de
raconter deux millions mais c'est la
fortune eposino anciens naturellement ah
bon
la fortune la fortune alentours est pas
tous tombés à la renverse
parce qu'une bande de [ __ ] et floch
2000 en l'air et que charles ix en soit
la bouche ouverts j'ai toujours des
plots été verni c'est vrai il est vernie
ce petit ce qu'il fait il le fait sans
l'avoir jamais appris je passe ou telle
étoile et les néo écossais s'étaient
donnés des épisodes qui font des choses
à me sentir bien le reconnaître il est
des matins c'est une fille lou le feu
mais c'est vrai nous ferons hippolyte
vous devriez être très courte content
quand envoie aussi j'étais même le droit
de trouver curieux l'otan le père d'une
fraise pour lui aujourd'hui vous ma mère
vous trouvez que l'on tous très bien
d'un temps je connais la chanson dès
qu'il ya prepaid tout est merveilleux
c'est calfatage me mettre à faire le
comptoir des voyages comme il est merola
ils savaient qu'ils avaient été reçus
aux éliminatoires
il savait certainement que julie serait
glissée hier pourquoi ils
s'intéressaient pas du tout monsieur
partait en week-end le concours ils s'en
fichaient comme d'une pomme
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire avec des
zigotos de ce calibre là se foutent même
ce qui les intéresse monsieur fait face
à côté des graphistes télégraphiste pour
le long pour charme mais ces télégrammes
pour monsieur charles baur merci le
gramme pour monsieur chère bravo lot
honteux biz les bouclettes fifi et dodo
se sentir moins des petits camarades oui
c'est mon monsieur monsieur
ah oui votre fils monsieur non monsieur
n'est pas avec le mr et puis pas vous
dire monsieur mon fils est chez moi
monsieur parfaitement monsieur et si
vous m'autorisez je prends pouvant vous
dire que le vôtre est en fugue galante
oui monsieur et avec une femme voulait
savoir c'est pas ta vie tu t'es sûr vous
donnez vos enfants monsieur mais
permettez moi de dire répond fils en
drones au concours je vous salue bien
la préface de ce pensum tollé
qu'est ce que maman et roger braqueront
blanc oui du maire a annoncé voir les
fleurs les fleurs pour d'ici à mai c'est
incroyable on vient est un nouvel os
longs à 2 heures précises à deux heures
mais dans l'état dans l'état où il est
dans un temps où il échangera l'état il
a créé spectre était sous le robinet ça
les changera d'idée et à sortir un peu
de son lit peut se montrer un peu tout
de même
c'est vrai ici des raisons bien une
faune bière on passe entend rentrer à
sortir à courir la chambre de monsieur
ville on le voit pas on le voit jamais
scénarisé après des génisses contre
aurait il en mourra pas enfin voilà le
rpf se dérangent on lui amène un camion
de son domicile
on n'est pas qu'il réponde à ces jours
là laissez moi tranquille j'ai été
plaqué par robert oui bon on arrangera
ça or henri est venu exprès pour nous
annoncer sa belle était hier soir au
palais de chaillot ce matin tu passais
un quartier il est monté ces gens
retirent qu'est ce que ce prix peut lui
amener à ce petit bonjour moi c'est tout
de même un succès un résultat
extraordinaire du continent évidemment
en tout cas ça ne pouvait pas mieux
tomber
s'il y avait des suites heureuses de ce
côté là ce serait une distraction à ce
qui est arrivé
quelle suite peut être qu'il y ait ce
qu'on sait
répétons ben oui ça va mieux
tu fais pas ta toilettes tu n'es pas
rentré 7 lui il paraît
allez embrasse moi nous nous sommes dit
des choses bien désagréable oublions
tout ça si nous pouvons eva traz et je
ne devais pas pour le plaisir je sais en
tout cas du label chaussée je ne serai
jamais connu on verra hop
n'en parlons plus dépêche toi on va
manger armée tu vas pas l'attraper
écoute c'est fini l'histoire de la gifle
nous sommes embrassés c'est oublier en
danger le pendu alors je te l'envoie au
projet halo 2 mon petit dit mon petit je
leur ai dit à mon grand c'est vrai
qu'elle a rejeté aujourd'hui toi n 17 et
déjà 17
pourquoi pas pour lui un bon moyen on
s'aperçoit de ces choses là tout d'un
coup le temps passe moins et ben oui
parbleu ah c'est toi
ça passe neuf soif pourquoi je pars
parce qu en bavardant comme ça on aurait
pu boire quelque chose un apéritif la
banque au port bah oui mais s'il y en a
pas là on est en voie jamais si tu veux
je peux aller chercher
voilà mon petit je voudrais d'abord
faire appel à toi pour un petit tour
d'adressent j'ai entre les mains un
paquet de lettres que ton frère a dû
laisser traîner moi je trouvais selleck
tout à fait par hasard
mais je voudrais pas que l'on puisse
tomber dans les mains de ta mère a
fortiori du ta grand mère elle pourrait
ne pas mettre au cul tu dois savoir
quand on fait un garde son courrier dans
le bureau de sa chambre je suppose
dans un des petits tiroirs mettons tuant
durera de droite tu n'en
tous et comme ton frère et personnel si
s'apercevait que par étourderie il a
laissé traîner ses lettres pourrait
supposer c'est quoi tous et comme il est
exagéré en tout alors je compte sur toi
pour que ce petit paquet regagne sa
place sans que charles est à s'alarmer
de quoi que ce soit pour le ménager un
peu c'est ainsi il a une contrariété le
pogo je peux compter sur toi d'accord il
y verra que du feu soit tranquille
parfait parfait
bon alors maintenant voici ce que j'ai à
te dire évidemment assez bizarre il et
les circonstances dans l'avion où
l'homme ou à un homme
toi moi ou les hommes un père de famille
par exemple peut se voir contraints par
un ensemble de considérations à à
envisager disant l'autre telle ou telle
solution qui au premier abord lui aurait
paru ou aurait pu lui paraît
inenvisageable
tu me suis pas enfin oui
tu imagines bien je pense que le bonheur
est peut-être un bien grand mot mais
disons la situation rêvée tu imagines
bien disent que je serai très heureux
qu'il me fut possible de procurer un ton
frère cette situation dont ils rêvent
tamer ce réseau réseau si je crois j'en
suis sûr parce qu'on projets si et je le
crois je peux m'adresser à toi comme une
grande personne faut que tu me donnes ta
parole que tout ce que je vais te dire
restera entre nous et nita mais un îlot
normands sont rien tu peux compter sur
toi vrai pas parfait nouveau parfum
alors voici voilà
voici ce qui se passe
c'est en un sens assez inespéré je crois
qu'il ne faut pas faire l'autruche il
faut regarder les choses en face
oublions si tu veux pour un moment le
couac le côté des femmes le savent la
toi et moi cette jeune comtesse
polonaise et sympathique dont nous avons
déjà parlé seraient disposées matthew
dear dans l'on demande mon petit faut
jamais compter cinq minutes avec ce
nombre de téléphone allô oui à
convaincre ap
il exclut ce fier mada
décidément mon appareil je suis rouge de
confusion mais mais oui voyez vous le le
premier grand prix en fait vous êtes
vous demandé ba1
évidemment évidemment il n'est pas comme
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mise en scène par lui même la presse que
nous venons d'avoir le plaisir de jouer
pour vous ce soir et d'andré roussin
[Musique]
bouquet quoi et de roger à
avec anne rodier
[Musique]
ma famille
question pas visite
[Musique]
germaine de france
andré rousselet
[Musique]
et simone renant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]